is jason whitney the dallas cowboys
joining me here live on the phone on the
rich eisen show how are you jason i'm
doing well rich uh coming off a big win
so glad to join
you yeah five and one i mean nobody as
you know
i know you know a lot of you don't pay
attention too much to the paparazzi but
nobody nobody saw that one coming jason
did you guys
use that as some of the fuel heading
into uh seattle last week
yeah i mean we we're close knit team i
mean obviously we knew it was going to
be tough going up to seattle playing the
defending champs and
uh they're really really good and uh
they controlled you know not only the
defending chance but they've started
this season now off just like they
finished last year so we knew it was
going to be tough but our team just
really a relentless group of guys that
played hard believed in each other and
fortunately made some big plays to get
the win there
other than that what is the difference
with this five in one start and the feel
that you have on a balanced offense
what's been the difference in your mind
jason
well i think you're just seeing the
identity of our football team we really
take a lot of pride and put a lot of
work this all season and running the
football and we have the three
first-round offensive linemen that we've
invested in and and uh they're playing
really well our entire offensive line
demarco murray running the football so
and i think our defense defense is
playing a lot better and and just
rallies to the ball and gets three and
out gets turnovers so it's given us a
chance uh we have to play that way to
give ourselves a chance to win games and
compete but i think just coming off the
last three years and playing week 17
chance to win the division and coming up
short a little bit of a mentality that
we just got to execute better and we we
can't really talk about it we got to go
be about it and our actions got to speak
louder in our words and so
we worked really hard and put the ti the
time in necessary to give yourself a
chance and paying off for us right now
but there's still a lot of football to
play we need to play our best football
moving forward
well obviously a lot of people are
wondering if demarco murray can last the
season getting as many carries as he's
as he's gotten are you concerned about
that
no really not i mean i think
um you've seen some of the other guys
too with with lance dunbar and
randall that we have that that they can
they're starting to get more
opportunities too but demarco just he's
a true pro
he works really hard he's in his fourth
year i think he's
he's kind of embracing this opportunity
that he has and
kind of working behind this offensive
line so he's strong he's physical he's
fast he's tough i mean everything you
want so he's playing really good right
now and i think he really he embraces
that role of
being in every down back and carrying
those 25 30 carries a game and
we'll continue to give it to him so
that's just the way we're going to play
if he gets tired the other guys will
step in but i think he's uh he's built
to handle this workload
now you got the giants who have had some
success in your building jason and two
weeks ago the talk after your overtime
win
in houston was as much
about the crowd noise being a problem
for your offense at your home stadium as
it was you actually winning the game are
you
i guess concern might be a different
word but what are your thoughts about
the the the fa the the giants coming
into this house in a crucial game for
you this weekend
yeah well i mean
they're a good football team i mean
they've won you know two super bowls
here in the last few years and i'm just
they're really good all around and i
know they play they had a tough game
against philadelphia on sunday night but
you go watch those other games they're
really good i mean obviously eli and
jason pierre-paul and just across the
board so they're a tough team they're
well coached and we know we're going to
get their best shot really our first
chance at a division game so
we don't playing on the crowd and always
being a factor i mean there was a lot of
texans fans there and i think
you know the opposing teams they always
want to come to to atm t stadium
and see it and be a part of it but uh
you know we're confident those cowboys
fans will come and be loud and um
it's gonna be a tough game for us
against the giants
last minute i have you
that terence williams catch in seattle
that huge third and 20 conversion that
big time play
that helped you win that game
was tony romo targeting you or terence
williams
well
i think he was targeting uh both of us
no i think he was uh he was really going
to terrance um
you know tony just does such a good job
in those situations his ability to
create and improvise and make plays down
the field and uh i think once we saw him
scrambling you know we have areas of the
field that we try to attack and um you
know just
unbelievable job by tony's keeper alive
we're all trying to go get the first
down and
what a throwing catch by those two um so
i kind of thought it was coming to me
and then last second saw terence running
over there and thankfully he was coming
and i saw him because uh he made a
fabulous play getting his feet down and
really and that was the play of the game
that's what allowed us to keep those
drives going
go down and get a touchdown we were down
three going into that play so just
tony's done in his whole career did you
see uh good to pay off did you think he
was overthrown do you think he was
overthrowing and then you turn around oh
yeah great catch is it one of those no
no no yes type moments for you well i
didn't know i mean i i not that i
thought it that was the case i was just
trying to go get the ball you know and
so uh when he scrambled we're all trying
to get the first down but if you see him
he sees terence the entire time kind of
signaling him a little bit to get to the
sideline and uh man he dropped the dime
it was unbelievable throw and catch he
did
what a catch what a grab and what a
record you guys have jason thanks for
joining me uh good luck against the
g-men and we'll chat further down the
line all right sounds good thanks for
having me on
you bet that is jason witten here on the
rich eisen show the rich eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern
on audience
you